[Applause]
good morning everyone
let me first
first of all welcome all of you welcome
all of you here
um of course from my side as well um mrs
president of the commission dear ursula
it's a tremendous pride for us to uh to
welcome you you here it's a great great
honor
we are here to uh to mark a first step
in in in a journey
that has started quite some time ago
actually it's almost a year ago that in
the midst of the covet uh crisis
we saw in belgium what we have and we
saw this incredible position
that we have in the meantime the rest of
the world has discovered the position
that we have everyone knows the
important role that we have
played in fighting this covet discovered
pandemic but the real question we had
was we know what we have now
what is necessary to make sure that 10
years 20 down 20 years down the road we
still will be at the core of so many
things happening in in in healthcare and
in
in in bioscience and this is the uh this
is the journey that we started that we
started together um we used the uh the
help of an outside partner of bcg who
was very instrumental in helping us and
in really connecting this very diverse
cluster that we have in belgium and this
is one of the characteristics is that we
are not just good in one element of the
chain we are actually good in so many
different elements of of the chain
the whole idea is we are great today but
what is necessary to make sure that we
can maintain this uh this position now
of course uh we do this in a european on
a european scale ursula i think you have
demonstrated over the last months that
is europe we succeed when we work
together
we succeed when we when we connect the
dots and we know that the exercise that
is being done here is of course a
belgian exercise but it is made within a
broader within a broader perspective and
so we're extremely happy to have you uh
to have you here um i think ursula over
the last uh over the last uh two years i
should say you're really shown of what
you are capable of in europe what we are
capable of when we bring everyone
together and what we are capable of when
we have the right leadership and we're
extremely happy that you have led us
through this crisis together with the
european commission and we're of course
extremely happy that you are here to uh
to support the the strategic exercise
that we have started ladies and
gentlemen ursula from delay
[Applause]
thank you so much prime minister dear
alexander
ministers state secretaries
distinguished guests and i'm very glad
to see the grand senior
of the vaccines professor peter piert
here in the audience too
i'm delighted to join you for this
indeed official launch of the belgium
biopharma platform today and i'm
delighted to join you especially because
it is in person
that we meet here today
and i'm explicitly mentioning this
because
a physical meeting today
would not have been possible
without the success story of the
european vaccination campaign
but this european vaccination campaign
this success story
would not have been possible without
belgium
it was in belgium
where the new mrna the life-saving mrna
vaccines have been produced for the very
first time at large scale
it was belgium
which played a key role in the clinical
trials
and it is belgium
from which europe sends a big part
of the vaccine it's exporting to
countries all over the world
i had the pleasure to visit pfizer the
fisa site in poors
it is really a true vaccine powerhouse
like so many of the world leading farm
innovation centers you have here in this
country
so today i want first and foremost
to thank you
for the steadfast support that you have
shown
you personally alexander the prime
minister
but also belgium as a whole this was
outstanding and from the bottom of my
heart many many thanks for that
i also warmly welcome the same as you've
said european direction
of the biopharma strategy that is
presented today
belgium provides and i can tell because
i have a novel i oversee the 27 member
states you provide an incredibly
conducive enabling environment for the
biopharma and biotech industries
you have world-class universities
you have well-known hospitals
you have a
experienced and talented workforce you
attract from all over the world
and you have a very strong focus on
innovation
and it is good to see that you are
building on this strength
with your new biopharma strategy a
strategy that puts european cooperation
at its core
ladies and gentlemen
indeed this year has shown
why the farm and biotech sector is such
a strategic asset for our union
the whole world has been called off
guard by a covet 19.
but today if you look at the results now
after 10 month of vaccination campaign
we have not only
more than 75 percent of adults in the
european union fully vaccinated
but and this is where we should really
take pride in
we have also exported more than one
billion
of vaccine doses to over 150 countries
we have made good on our promise
that at least every second dose produced
here in the european union will be
exported shipped abroad and indeed it is
more than every second dose that has
been produced here in the european union
that has been shipped abroad
so while others have isolated themselves
europe offered help
to the world
it was a choice we made together
it is the
result of our joint effort and i really
think we can be proud of that
but we have not yet defeated covet 19
unless we can control the virus in india
in africa in latin america
and across the globe
and this is why team europe that is the
european commission and the european
member states
are now investing more than 1 billion
euro in establishing
mrna
manufacturing capacities in africa i
know that belgium with its expertise and
with its know-how
can contribute a great deal
to this strategic project
and we will do more
i've started together with the
u.s president joe biden a vaccine
partnership eu us vaccine partnership
to beat the global pandemic
and we've set ourselves the goal to have
70 percent of the global population
vaccinated by next year
the european union will donate more than
500 million doses within the next month
and also the united states will do their
share but of course other countries have
to step up and to contribute to
and therefore i'm working very closely
now with the g20 presidency that is
italy mario draghi of italy and the
american president that this weekend at
the g20 summit we rally
the leaders around the goal to have 70
percent of the world's population
vaccinated by next year and thus to step
up the donations and to step up
the the manufacturing of life-saving
vaccines for the whole world
this is the focus at the moment being
but of course at the same same time we
have to prepare ourselves for future
health threats
a great european jack de la once said
in the face of a crisis
you need both
a fireman
as well as an architect
so um the fire fighter i'd say other
vaccines
but let's talk for a moment about the
two pillars
of the future architecture
the lessons we've drawn out of this
crisis first of all we have created a
new health emergency preparedness and
response authority long name
in short hera
hera's task is to better prepare for
health emergencies
to pro to detect them more earlier
and promptly
and to respond collectively
all three things we didn't have when
coveted started we were not prepared we
had no clue how to to detect it early
enough and we had no joint cooperation
in place we all had to learn that
so the scope of hero will reach from
collective procurement for example of
protective equipment medicines and
vaccines
to coordinating for example the rules
for testing and quarantine and all you
can think of what is necessary if you're
faced with such a cross-border health
threat
we will also strengthen the european
pharmaceutical sector and the health
ecosystem
in which belgium is such a prominent
actor
and this brings me to the second point
here we have the innovation and the
scientific capacity here in belgium and
in the european union
we have the private sector knowledge if
i look at do you hear assembled here in
this room i mean there's a huge amount
of knowledge and scientific and
innovation capacity
and we have competent national
authorities
so what we need now
is to bring all these elements together
and to underpin them with massive
investment funding
let me give you some examples take the
european innovation council that for
example supports now the highly
innovative smes
in the area of infectious diseases
or just recently
this european innovation council
announced financial support
for belgium biotech company that
develops tools for precision microbiome
profiling
and of course then there is our huge
recovery fund we call it next generation
eu 800 billion euros in today's today's
prices
and here the member states are using
these funds
indeed to make them available
to the research community to build
resilience healthcare capacities and to
invest in innovation
belgium
for example prime minister was very
happy to see is investing in a biotech
school
are you investing
into research and development supporting
the production of medical
radio isotopes
so all this
taking
the research capacities and
joining them with the necessary funding
bringing it all together all this helps
us
to prepare better for future health
threats
and i think there is no better return on
investment than that
distinguished guests this is our
european way to do things
while of course repairing the damage of
the crisis
we are investing in a better future
and it is great to see that with this
biopharma platform you are creating
today
you are also going in absolutely the
same direction
so i count on belgium to continue to
drive european cooperation in the future
i count on belgian by enriching eu
programs for example like horizon europe
i count on you and engaging in our new
hera authority
and of course i count on you by
mobilizing your brilliant
researchers and entrepreneurs
i specially welcome the ideas you
develop in your strategy on how to
address potential vulnerabilities in our
supply chains this is also a big topic i
will not go in depth
but this will be also a big topic at g20
this weekend in rome the summit
the supply chains that have been
interrupted by the lockdowns and coveted
pandemic all over the world and we see
now how difficult it is to bring them
back in place but what we also learn is
our huge dependency on supply chains so
we have to look how to diversify our
supply chains how to strengthen them i'm
not talking the word to only unshoring
them that's not the solution
but to be more diverse in the supply
chains to have a strategic reserve that
is here on the continent but also to be
able to strengthen our supply chains
that will be one of the big lessons we
have to learn from this pandemic
so
i want you to know
as i've looked at the concept of this
platform
that whatever you plan also regarding
the supply chains from strategic top
stockpiles to
the ramping up of the local production
rest assure that you have the full
support of the european commission
ladies and gentlemen
extending our positions as leading
biopharma hubs
will bring benefits to all
patients get a higher quality of care
they get an easier access to access to
innovative therapies
the economy gets a boost
as we will attract not only the funding
i was just describing but of course also
international investment
and our society at large benefits from
this tightly woven network you have of
research institute and enterprises
we are in this together
a strong belgium makes our union
stronger
and a strong union makes belgium
stronger
so let's get to work thank you very much
for the attention